yeah welcome to this game playing
Superman five I am beat this guy
recently or recently is wrong just kept
law firm games to go in the session but
then I played before I think with the
bangko and amazingly he took on c4 by me
i'm really surprised how many strong
players play this absolute mine online
it's already leading to problems for
black button they play it anyway not
sure not sure why queen e 2 mm how how
do you continue 92 not sure I want I
want them to go to see form but this
clock sup home yeah okay it doesn't
matter him just um
did react at all okay on Knight b6 which
is his plan I'd like to go Knight a5
night a 595 though but annoying may be
here it's not
yeah maybe the saw plan with 96 was
wasn't so great he just ignores all this
I mean I'm used to that people ignore my
ideas all the time so I'm yeah still
maybe it is good for black so it's
possible he's got dumb para on d5
yeah it's some not cleared on what's
happening here
really why why why does he give up his
bishop ok I don't I don't get it just
because of this this is this threat here
Knight takes d5 yeah maybe
but now how to continue
if I drop back to defy God's will see 5
this is this is bad oh come on that's
just go ahead here and play on play for
the active active pieces active rogue on
d5
yeah I think this must be enough
activity ready for the point
so just struck rock d6 he plays queener
six it's a bit bit bit embarrassing but
I can just drop back keeping the
pressure on d6 term I can take you six
now or thinking about other plans what
about this I can take edge form ah yeah
the only way for him to ever win this
game as a blunder porn really yeah of
course he saw that in a split second um
yeah what do what to do now
I mean I can can maybe I can do
something against the with the with the
squeem this somewhat somewhat cut off
Queen I could have just taken d6 with
the with slide slide initiative in the
same game even but O'Kane it's not not
as serious some advantage or something
so what now maybe can't go looking for
or something getting even more activity
between h6 also
yeah this is still not not completely
easy for black despite the two pawns
yeah maybe Ruby five this looks like a
good move you know he never plays the
move I expect I mean this can mean two
things
Jeff
Jeff
yeah we're down to a rook endgame
he's got an extra porn
but it's sewn rather difficult to do
anything with it
tending c7 getting the es6 porn
check
gap it just adjust dead this position
basically hmm
j yeah of course you will win on time or
trying to win on time
Jeff
and for what check check
check
check draw offered
check
now he's playing on time with the bond
down in the rook endgame great I loved
his people and and now I can claim a
perpetual I mean just yeah no words no
words I mean you got to pawn up rook
endgame blunder two points I offered a
draw he declines to play on time and TD
clients weren't accepting a 34
repetition I mean what gal sorry if I if
I was pickering too much in this in this
game but sometimes you really don't know
what what you would you would you want
the same I mean all this is what was
really weird here I've got really good
good compensation for the porn I mean
for example I can I can just take d6 now
with with with a pretty pretty good
position it's just nothing happening he
like a set of G for you or any other
move basically you cannot do much and
g4s of course just stupid by me just
blundering this phone but yeah at the
end towards the drawn head game and so
we had this fun stuff happening at the
end yeah okay I hope you had some
entertainment at least